afortunadamente mi pluma ya ha regresado
a la vida recordemos que a nuestra
función 1 / x y vamos a evaluarla en el
valor de menos punto 001 cuándo
sustituimos nos da como resultado el
valor de menos 1000 esto quiere decir
que cuando tenemos un valor muy cercano
al 0 por la izquierda tenemos valores
cada vez más pequeños de hecho podemos
utilizar nuestra imaginación qué pasará
si ponemos el menos punto 0001 pues
obtendremos el menos 10.000 y si ponemos
otros valores podremos obtener el menos
un millón menos 10 millones menos 6
millones todos ellos pero ahora
analizaremos qué pasará cuando x toma un
valor positivo por ejemplo si tomamos el
0.01 nos dará como resultado el valor de
100 si tomamos ahora el 0.0 fallos en la
toma el 0.001 obtendremos como resultado
1000 perfecto observemos que cuando
nuestra función uno entre x nos
acercamos al 0 por la izquierda
obtendremos valores más
más y más pequeños pero si nos acercamos
por la derecha
vamos a ir obteniendo valores cada vez
más grandes mientras del lado izquierdo
nuestros valores son negativos del lado
derecho nuestros valores son positivos
pero bien como podremos ver la gráfica
de esta función supongamos que este
nuestro eje de las x y este de acá será
nuestro eje de las pies hagamos las
cosas más coloridas primero quiero que
notemos que cuando x es muy muy negativo
o dicho de otra manera cuando x está
cercano al infinito negativo realmente
nuestra función toma valores muy
cercanos al cero mientras que cuando nos
acercamos al 0 por la izquierda como ya
habíamos visto en nuestra función irá
decreciendo voy a poner en las flechas
para que nos dé esa impresión
ahora bien observemos qué pasa en otro
lado cuando x es muy grande
nuestra función va a tender al cero
mientras que cuando nos acercamos a cero
por la derecha como ya vimos nuestra
función irá creciendo mientras que por
la izquierda
mi función tiende al menos infinito
derecha mi función entiende al más
infinito
ahora escribamos esto en una notación
adecuada voy a decir que el límite
cuando x tiende al cero con un signo de
más es decir por el lado derecho
de la función 1 / x
estamos diciendo que cuando x tiende al
0 por la derecha pues esto en la gráfica
se ve que es infinito esto también ya lo
habíamos visto en la tabla y ahora voy a
decir que el límite pero esta vez cuando
x tiende al 0 por la izquierda o con un
signo de menos arriba de nuestra función
uno entre x observemos que pasa vayamos
a nuestra gráfica para ver claramente
qué es lo que está sucediendo cuando
nosotros nos acercamos al 0 por la
izquierda
nuestra función cada vez toma valores
más pequeños es decir que este límite es
menos infinito pero como podemos
interpretar esta información obtenida
veamos que el límite cuando x tiende a 0
por la derecha es infinito y cuando x
tiende a 0 por la izquierda es menos
infinito si los dos valores de nuestros
límites tanto por la derecha como por la
izquierda son distintos voy a decir que
el límite de mi función es indefinido
es muy importante que no olvidemos que
si el límite por la derecha y el límite
por la izquierda no coinciden
entonces el límite que estamos buscando
es indefinido pero bien pasemos a otro
ejemplo en esta ocasión voy a tomar el
límite cuando x tiende a cero pero de
una función distinta
esta vez tomar es la función 1 / x
cuadrada
qué es lo que pasará con esta función
cómo podemos darnos cuenta de este
límite para esto quiero hacer una
gráfica desde el principio este va a ser
nuestro eje de las equis y este de acá
va a ser nuestro eje de las 10
voy a hacerlo gráficamente desde el
principio porque la idea intuitiva de
hacer una gráfica nos va a dar la
respuesta de este límite y antes que
nada no quiero que olvidemos que todo
número elevado al cuadrado distinto de
cero siempre es positivo igual que en el
caso anterior voy a hacer una tabla para
comparar los valores de x y mi función 1
/ x cuadrado
tomemos para empezar el valor del punto
1 punto 1 al cuadrado es punto 0 1 y 1
entre punto 0 1 es 100 pero si tomamos
ahora el valor de menos punto 1 y al
elevarlo al cuadrado no sale 0.01 y 1
entre 0.0 1 nos da otra vez 100 es decir
los dos valores nos van a ir a dar al
100 positivo que pasará si tomamos otro
valor tomemos por ejemplo ahora el punto
01 al evaluarlo en nuestra función
obtendremos el valor de 10.000 y de
manera análoga al otro valor negativo si
tomamos el menos punto 01 también
obtendremos el valor de 10.000 ok pero
esto en mi grafica me va a dar una
interpretación muy bonita
cuando x se acerca al menos infinito
nuestros valores son muy cercanos al 0
mientras que cuando x se acerca al 0 por
la izquierda nuestros valores se van a
infinito del lado derecho de nuestra
gráfica de una manera muy simétrica va a
pasar lo mismo cuando x toma valores muy
grandes
nuestra función se va a acercar al 0 y
mientras x tome valores cada vez más
cercanos al 0 por la derecha
nuestra función se va a el infinito
genial cambiamos el color rojo para ver
nuestros resultados con más claridad el
límite cuando extiende al 0 por la
izquierda en esta función 1 / x cuadrada
como ya vimos es infinito pero si
nosotros tomamos el límite cuando x
tiende al 0 pero por la derecha de la
función misma uno entre x cuadrada
también es infinito ojo en este caso los
dos límites son iguales por la derecha y
por la izquierda los dos tienden a
infinito
entonces podemos decir que el límite
cuando x tiende a cero será infinito
pues el límite por la derecha y el
límite por la izquierda coinciden en el
valor de infinito este ejemplo me parece
realmente muy bello pues es la primera
vez que nos sale del resultado a
legítimo infinito aunque esto suene un
poco filosófico tal vez algo metafísico
infinito es la respuesta correcta pero
bueno en los siguientes vídeos ver
algunos ejemplos más de límites e
introducir la definición formal del
límite no se nos pierdan